the partners of meter talk I get some
partner shaft skip niched whom upping
each card from the choker West Accord
own invoice UN Bharat to American the
jamendo soo lapel daily fugitive our
enemies are not the refugees were
fleeing from war conflict and
persecution our enemies are the people
traffickers you know what we are doing
in fact we are not changing doubly now
now we have put dirty inside the Dublin
system that is what we have decided
instead of changing the Dublin system
definitely and make a fair share between
the Member States and European Union
fight moral fight maharloka Oreo de las
acciones O'Day who Lobby who Rahim
Kazuma justice Ella police alemannic to
the salon
Kim sell a up his own toothpaste Liberty
distally feed to the opposition
Democratic Daniel election rollers like
Jack Seville a bow back the support
population via Finland's in meeting the
gross flesh things on migrations please
decide and destroy in various justice
are selfish country and these rough
maths three thousands a statement of
Maxim guard in town Whitman buffoon
these are clear the coffins and building
fences and walls to keep people out is
not a solution it will only increase the
suffering of the people who have already
suffered the unimaginable
rarely have so many people being
displaced in the world as they are right
now but rarely have so few European
countries stepped up and being prepared
to act stefan de rien tall initiative a
new a big Gouda coalition emiram and
rely on donna visa leaders Coco bear the
villa calendar audit a sunset a chez
paree ulam triple a social Europe
requires fair and balanced growth that
leads to the creation of decent quality
jobs such a situation in Europa profit
ring and and triple-a and Suzy are
liberating ROM disappears even that's
the our mood in Europa Grey's Anatomy
and arrived I'm fertile the operation
before only an order under the HC they
are mods currency we must promote the
values of remove maintainer Appiah Union
stands for we did more posting in Europe
not less the principle of remuneration
for the protection of workers is very
much wider than the original directive
which refers to pay this is likely to
have an adverse impact on small
businesses it is objective can support
of a program Authority called low
visitor 14 item in your era so today's
on